♪♪
YEAH, I WAS A BIG SCIENCE NERD.
DEFINITELY A VIRGIN.
THAT'S ME.
I WENT TO SPACE CAMP
FOR FOUR YEARS.
I COULD GO ON AND ON ABOUT THAT,
BUT I DON'T...
I DON'T THINK THAT POPULARITY
WAS MAYBE AT THE TOP OF MY
PRIORITY LIST IN HIGH SCHOOL.
I WAS LIKE, "WHY BE POPULAR
WHEN YOU COULD DISSECT FROGS?"
[ British accent ]
WELL, I GREW UP LIKING SCIENCE
AND THEN WENT ON
TO DO A MATH DEGREE --
OR MATHS DEGREE,
AS YOU CALL IT IN MY COUNTRY.
SO I WAS PRETTY COOL.
I THINK ALL THE OTHER KIDS
IN THE CLASS WERE LIKE,
"YEAH, THAT KID
WHO'S PRETTY GOOD AT PHYSICS,
HE'S THE ONE TO HANG OUT WITH."
SCIENTISTS ARE BOTH NERDY
AND HOT.
I MEAN, THEY HAVE TO BE NERDY.
TO BE NERDY JUST MEANS
YOU'RE REALLY PASSIONATE
ABOUT SOMETHING,
AND YOU JUST WANT
TO KEEP DRIVING
TO FIND OUT
MORE AND MORE ABOUT IT
AND MAKE IT
MORE A PART OF YOUR LIFE.
THAT, TO ME,
IS HOT AND ATTRACTIVE.
IF YOU'RE PASSIONATE
ABOUT SOMETHING,
THAT'S, LIKE, THE GREATEST
QUALITY YOU COULD HAVE.
AND BEING ABLE
TO WEAR THE UNIFORM --
IT SOMETIMES HELPS
WITH THE LADIES.